hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to universe sandbox now this
is a game about space but not just about
space it's about simulating so many
different things that go on in space and
I love space many of you may know that
about me but I am a living embodiment of
the space companion cube there is
nothing I like more than space and if
there was a program for volunteers to go
in the space with like a hundred percent
chance of dying from death by space I
would be first in line to go to space if
there was a mission to colonize Mars and
they needed brave volunteers or stupid
volunteers I would be there so fast I
would abandon everything on earth to go
into space and I would love it I would
love every struggle of it I would love
the horror and entirely my numbing ly
terrible experience that it may or may
not be with certain death on the horizon
just for a chance to go into space
but that's besides the point I'm here to
play universe sandbox which is a really
cool game that I've been playing around
with in trying to understand I've been
taking some tutorials I have been
fiddling around and I blew up the Sun
didn't mean to do that but it happened
hey Yolo and whatever so now oh no we're
the tutorial go I was supposed to be
doing a tutorial here ah hang on let me
get to that real quick okay now we're
back whoa alright calm down there a
little bit let's slow it there we go
little little slower there we go oh it's
so pretty
oh it's so pretty okay I can arrange
objects in a solar system but this is
blowing my mind right now
and I also blew up the Sun and I'm gonna
try not to do that but I'm just getting
started here I'll click the chart button
again okay many included simulations to
explore go to home let's see open Samia
Oh
love space okay
don't see the galaxy collision oh oh
it's so pretty
oh it's so pretty oh my god it's so
beautiful I'm not even joking you guys
it's so pretty like can you even imagine
the scale of this interaction like how
huge this is because it may seem small
and this is just a not entirely accurate
interpretation of what would happen if
two galaxies collided but we are zipping
by at what looks like a million years
every second this is a million years a
second can you even imagine a million
years imagine them going by every second
and that explains what's happening here
and every tiny speck every speck every
speck is probably a Sun a star that's
bigger than our Sun just so you'd be
able to see it from this distance it's
so big the universe is so big and these
galaxies which have hundreds of billions
of stars hundreds of billions don't
quote me on that but billions and
billions of stars there are billions and
billions of galaxies as many stars are
in a single galaxy there there's more
galaxies in the entire universe itself
the universe is so impossibly large your
brain can't comprehend how big it is
space is so cool space so much okay
anyway I need to stop nerd again I love
space I don't know I haven't played this
game sooner I I know I knew about it I
just I hadn't played it so
oh okay create oh I can create a preset
well looks like the galaxies are gonna
be in turmoil for a while see the
Andromeda galaxy which is our nearby
neighbor galaxy nearby in the Galactic
sense but it's gonna collide with our
galaxy in about what a billion years two
billion years I forget exactly when it's
gonna collide but this is gonna happen
to our galaxy very soon it's gonna be
chaos and then it's gonna form a new
galaxy and it's gonna spiral off into
the distance like it's so cool there's
so many cool things okay earth and earth
let's get double earth here Oh Oh what
happened it formed a new earth holy crab
that was just in a matter of hours oh
that's so cool that ain't Earth oh it's
2.01 over Earth how did it get the point
oh one oh that's so cool what happened
oh it's so cool but I've got powers too
so I'm gonna I don't know I don't know
what this is well apparently fiddles a
rave on the new earth Wow go everybody
that just died all right party time I
suppose I don't know what that's doing
exactly okay how about pulse blink what
I don't know what that did I don't know
what any of these do I haven't taken all
the tutorials yet so I'm not entirely
sure fireworks is not doing anything
material hydrogen and silicon sand in
your face Oh what that's how I wanted oh
it's going oh oh that's so cool oh
they're the fireworks oh cool Oh
oh man I'm having too much fun okay so I
don't know what those are but it's cool
the Fargo guys are all going to earth
it's gaining mass oh I wonder if I give
it enough hydrogen if it'll definitely
turn into a star ooh oh that's so cool
oh that's so cool the way just let me
give these I'm gonna give these a lot
more mass let's put this yeah they do
this to the let me just let me go all
out okay this is a lot of mass go for it
baby
but something seems very uh
fertilisation II about this how come on
all that hydrogen did nothing spread I
want more hydro Jan on this I want much
more on the music in this game it's
really cool too by the way
it's so cool okay I think we're making
progress hang on we're making progress
here we've got a slowly
moon oh okay I just needed to be on a
bigger scale okay so the mass of the
particle is gonna be much higher let's
put the each particles of a hundred
moons no not that oh come on
stop being stupid here I know it's
hydrogen but just deal with me okay
damn it come on okay apparently hydrogen
doesn't want to get any heavier I don't
know why but that is what it is okay
let's let's put it faster then there we
go now it's growing now we're getting
somewhere
yeah oh how do I adjust okay off okay
there we go
I just need to turn auto-adjust off okay
now we're cooking with gas make this ten
thousand moons Oh have I been painting a
bunch of hydrogen way in the distance
oopsy poopsy huh that's gonna form a
star eventually just way way way out of
the way okay
make it slower then
there we go now we got it get in there
oh no jeez okay Oh God Oh we're kidding
oh my God we're getting massive now holy
crap it's 84 times the mass of Jupiter
holy balls it's pulling in every object
in the nearby area oh that's so cool I'm
turning everything to a star oh man it
might actually be massive enough to be a
star
oh that's so cool more more more more
more MORE oh how far away is that pole
net okay it'll be there eventually you
Jupiter's taking a beating it's got new
nipple formations all the crosses surf
I mean earth it's not Jupiter hope Oh
God well no it got big and then it
collapsed in on itself I think pretty
sure that's what happened more more more
more more more more more more II more
and more and more and more we got to go
another scale let's go I'm gonna put
more earths into this so that let's get
serious about this a thousand earth per
particle
oh whoa whoa whoa I don't know what
that's all but oh my god the gravity is
so intense that everything that missed
it
slang shattered into the distance it's
like a comet those are gonna come back
in about a million years oh there's so
cool
my computer can't handle the rendering
goodness it's so cool oh man it's so
cool maybe it got too big I have no idea
maybe that's all that hydrogen and
hydrogen can do for it I don't know okay
um let's see what can I add I could add
oh that's so cool um
I could add another star and it's watch
it collide I'd be cool
poink oh whoa hey whoa what the
pretty go where'd it go huh oh no no
edit what is happening Oh what is
happening slow it down baby
wait is that
wait this is a star this is a star of
1.4 times the mass of our Sun and it is
dwarfed by the size of the Sun that I
created out of two earths that's how big
I made the Sun I made to a point where
it wouldn't get any larger but that's
what happened it stopped accepting more
material and yet it looks like it's only
two point one five the mass of our Sun
but is 45 thousand kilometres radius but
I don't know I don't know we got to
figure this out hmm
something going weird here I'll speed it
up speed it up speed it up let's go
let's go let's go let's try that
that's so pretty goddamn
I could play this game for hours and
hours and hours and never get bored so
let's blow something up here I bet I can
add a black hole yeah
Sagittarius oh you want me to be on that
scale eh let's put you right there whoa
spacetime just got warped ah where to go
I can't find my black hole let's put
another one right there then oh well I
don't know where my black hole went but
it's there somewhere wolf and Earth I
don't know what that is
well well that happened all right Han
Earth and Moon real time oh oh oh this
real time ah nah that's so cool but so
terrifying oh my god you'll sometimes
people forget how big the moon actually
is like compared to the size of Earth
it's actually really uncommon that the
moon is so that the earth has a moon as
large as the moon is and the current
theory now it's a theory but I don't
know how accurate is or if it's very
very very accepted in the community I'm
pretty sure that the current theory is
that when the when the solar system was
being formed and the Sun was first
formed there was actually a pre earth
planet and then another earth-like
planet that was either bigger or smaller
and they collided
what happened in this collision is that
the smaller planet got destroyed and but
it scooped off a lot of material from
the proto-earth and all that material
started orbiting around earth and then
coalesced into what is the moon and I
think they confirm this because one when
they went with when they went to the
moon and brought back soil samples they
found that it was extremely similar to
the material that was on earth therefore
they assumed that it originally was part
of earth so this is actually a really
unique scenario and actually a lot of
theorists about you know life on other
planets say like maybe the moon and how
unique the moon is to earth is why
there's life on Earth and it doesn't
seem because there's a I forget what the
theory is but there's a read there's
like something paradox where if the
universe is so old and like earth life
is common oh my god the oceans are
evaporating well then that's not good
then why don't we see other life like
it's something paradox given how much
opportunity there must be and there's
about a number of theories why but this
is one of them because not only that
they also say that the the solid iron
core in the middle of the earth in the
center of the earth which has is
spinning and creating the magnetic field
for Earth is also unique and a result of
the original collision that happened in
Earth and that's why there's protection
from the magnetic field na storm of the
Sun and that's why it doesn't roast us
alive in addition to the atmosphere and
the moon combined to kind of churn the
oceans on earth and the right amount of
water like it's all very unique and
that's why there's life on Earth but who
knows no one really knows all I know is
that this is really cool and it's simin
very slow on my copy that's so cool
oh my god that's literally in the
minutes
oh man oh well there one there I want
the moon now all of Earth is not doing
so good
who would even orbits the fragments of
the moon look it's a glowing ball of
fragment oh so pretty
I will never stop nerding out I will
never stop hurting again one of my
favorite games of all times you know I
often forget when people ask me what my
favorite game is one of my favorite
games of all time is actually homeworld
it's a space RTS game but it's so
beautiful like the elegance of the world
around it and the story of why you're
playing the game it's also beautiful
collapsing moons oh oh oh man the moons
are chasing it down they're all trying
to take it out you can't stop me oh
that's so cool oh it's so cool I need I
need to come up with more clever
commentary than that it's so cool
because it is cool we all know it to be
cool but there's more to be said okay so
what I'm gonna do supernovas Oh
supernova in a galaxy hell yeah whoa
ah damn supernova stellar evolution of
our Sun okay so this is what's gonna
happen to our Sun and it's going by at
many many years per second but this is
what's gonna happen to our Sun as it
grows older because eventually I think
it's burning hydrogen right now it'll
eventually change and start burning
helium and then that will I think it
just did something there anyway stars
when they they go through phases
depending on how much initial mass they
have and how much initial mass they have
- determines how far into the fusion
process it goes like hydrogen fuses to
helium helium fuses to oxygen thank you
I can't remember my periodic table you
know the other one and then carbon and
then iron maybe not those it's been a
while okay it's been a while so but they
it goes farther in fusion depending on
which one it is it's a more energetic
process that requires more gravity and
so it it causes the star to grow I'm
pretty sure this was supposed to turn
into a white dwarf though that's what's
supposed to happen or said unless this
is what happened is is that what
happened oh it already happened I wasn't
paying attention okay um let's see if we
can actually catch that let's see let's
slow this down a little bit slow down
okay well goddamn it missed it again
that's right about four and a half
million billion years later
whoa whoa okay well sums happenin kids
getting bigger okay it's getting bigger
it's getting bigger it's getting bigger
eventually I think it's gonna turn into
a red giant which may have done just now
the radius is slowly climbing and then
it's gonna pop oh dammit god dammit
dammit missed it again okay big big dope
[ __ ] dammit
okay alright this is really hard to
catch because the events of it happening
is like in the span of a few years and
we're going by millions of years so I
don't think it's gonna work okay Oh
super supernova close-up real-time okay
oh that's so cool now it's really
interesting is we actually can tell or
someone with the right equipment would
be able to tell that a star was going
supernova before it actually exploded
because the reaction for this happening
happens in the very core of the star and
the result of it is there are neutrinos
that are shot out from the core of the
star and these go just about the speed
of light and the explosion does not so
when the neutrinos from the initial
reaction of the explosion happening gets
shot out they get shot out at nearly the
speed of light and they can be detected
because neutrinos interact very rarely
with any material in the universe
they're very low in terms of reactivity
so and what that means interactivity not
reactivity interactivity so they never
they hardly ever
hit any other particle in the universe
so they're very hard to detect but that
also means that when they're escaping
from the center of the star even though
there's an entire star is worth a
material they will not be able to be
stopped so they will continue out from
the star and then if there's someone to
detect it you would actually know oh
this star is blowing up well [ __ ] I kept
forgot a dye so fun fact there you go oh
that's so cool
speed it up a little bit oh so cool oh
so cool oh so cool so cool okay so I
will leave it with this one I am I love
this game I love space I love everything
about it I hope you guys enjoyed me
gigging out about space and talking
about things that I don't fully
understand but there's so much to learn
about space if you haven't seen it
already I would recommend watching
cosmos of the new series with Neil
deGrasse Tyson narrating and also the
older city was series with Carl Sagan's
Carl Sagan Carl Sagan science agency
they're really interesting series they
explore a lot of topics about space and
the most recent series is actually very
fun to watch I've watch it try it twice
through it explores a lot of topics not
just about space but about everything in
terms of science that's really
interesting to see so if you want to
know more there's tons of more resources
to learn about space and science and all
of these cool things I recommend always
learning because as stupid as I am and
as stupid as I seem that doesn't mean
that I don't appreciate intellectual
pursuits so thank you everybody so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed this
video I know I did thank you again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
you